elle voit tout ce qui se passe dans
l'émission elle voit tout ce qui se
passe en dehors de l'émission et gras
durs tu ne donneras ton avis tu vas voir
l'équipe autrement une fois de plus à
lui ma peau qui salit cyril merci pour
la jeune fille ça me fait plaisir
battant je vous ai jamais vu je tiens à
dire je n'ai jamais vu pour qui je vous
jure que c'est vrai rien on ne sait
jamais rencontrés je ne sais pas qui
c'est alors eu des rumeurs sur quelqu'un
je ne sais pas si c'est vous mais en
tout cas voilà je suis très dur aux
impayés des rumeurs sur pas mal de gens
par amour ah oui oui pourquoi on est
moche à voir les malvoyants les
versements a dit qu'elle était très
belle et ça l'est moins quand elle se
dandine qu'elle est belle ouais pas
votre voix sexy pas votre curiosité
pas du tout normalement vous êtes un peu
enquêteurs non j'ai décidé de jouer le
jeu on dévoilera son visage à la fin de
la saison et on dévoilera également le
visage des prochains chroniques urbaines
[Applaudissements]
oui match eric et 6 pas l'herbe on
s'arrête aussi hâte en 2002 monsieur
pascal kkk ordre bardot oui ma chérie
mammeri gchq donner quelque chose
merci c'est un pack c'est un paquebot t
sap à côté merci ma chérie merci alors
oui je vais dire bonjour à mathieu
mathieu tu m'as manqué voilà je sais que
tu m'aimes beaucoup mais j'ai
l'impression que tu me fuis les jeudis
ah non il va être là tous les jeudis
maintenant qu'on a fait et je vous dis
pendant les violences juste pour qui
pendant la pub je vous jure que c'est
vrai j'ai reçu une dar k énorme parce
que on a parlé de matthieu delormeau qui
habite chez moi et il ya katy ne
s'occupe de mac line renaud qui me dit
monsieur de mena j'ai reçu de loyer de
monsieur delormeau aujourd'hui pour
novembre après d'exclamation pour un fou
ouais à l'aube à l'écart gonflait
catherine oui mais le combat que le
chauffage n'a pas été allumés catherine
coma
[Rires]
jamais rien avec 5 euros combien il a
payé nos ventes merci street en avant
allait alors cook est connu pour ça que
quand m mathieu et je sais que tu
m'aimes aussi mathieu
la preuve j'ai les images pour quelques
est avec nous ou cookies qui nous
balance tout ce qui se passe dans
l'émission elle voit tous par d'où je
suis je suis quoi ça vient du coeur dans
la page
je suis quoi c'est pas du tout je suis
quoi je suis une une belle surprise
ouais et bien comme je suis une pote
pukki aussi je veux montrer des images
aux patrons s'il regarde bien ça va vous
plaire un quoi
[Musique]
je découvre ça c'est des connards
salomonais series série des seules ars
et que j'ai vécu c'est un ami mais c'est
que j'ai des caméras vous avez les
caméras cyril vous avez aussi des micros
et ça tombe bien moi je peux projet
droit il m'a dit oui moi ça va nous
ressortir sur moi ta main qui créent des
lois pour les autres et les lois pour
moi il sait maintenant que c'est pas moi
c'est lui qui a mis sa touche en donnant
la chance à ce que jean cyril sa mémoire
qu'est ce que vous faites à cyril
davantage pour le coup c'était au sens
figuré
même là ça ne passe pas mourir seul
durée non comment non mais c'est vrai
que non mais maintenant on est on est
lié dans les émissions c'est ce que j'ai
voulu dire et je me serais
maladroitement parce que la télé faut
aller vite on est lié dans les émissions
et vous êtes jeunes moi j'ai besoin de
vous on est on est bloqué il y aurait
d'autres choses
bien sûr la semaine dernière je vous
montrais en exclusivité les images de
votre première comédie musicale cyril ah
oui c'est vrai c'était magnifique
eh bien figurez-vous qu'on a déjà les
images de l'adhésion ici c'est un
spectacle pour plus comique que lyrique
certes mais mais on adore bienvenue à
bazens nommé
[Musique]
soussan
sinon ça
[Musique]
à quimper
carrez
dans ma tête c'est toujours un guerrier
guerrier
ça fait boum boum je vais bouffer le
[Musique]
olé
non mais
massa
[Musique]
lucas
straw que tu es bien chanter en pense
dgac j'ai l'intention de près de bourges
était mignon ça que tu es vivant même
pendant les pubs on le voit mais parce
que vous avez une petite propension à
changer les paroles des pas du tout et
je donnerai pas le sait pardonner vrai
vous pouvez mettre des noms au cul de
temps à rire c'est quand même vous qui
mettez votre main sur le postérieur de
génie qu'est ce qui peut leur est dédié
à suivre non motivée et où la foule
motiver un et pas vraiment gratuit
c'est ça hein tu aimerais bien repartir
à tout ça maintenant
oui non non non il n'a pas caché qu on
veut pas lui au pas dans le foot arrêté
tard est malade et dire que c'est nul
mais il joue dans quelle équipe
franck ribéry équipe de france ou telle
autre chose pour notre plus grand
plaisir
le roman d'amitié entre casta et baba
continue ah oui avec une petite variante
cette semaine
cast a décidé de se rebeller non si mais
suffisamment pour qu'elle ait une autre
baba ans je ne crois pas non c'est pas
encore ça
[Musique]
et si ça va c'est l'autriche et copines
[Applaudissements]
bouffon
bajaur est avec toi époque je rumine sa
chair une bande dessinée
je dois être ensemble rigole papillon
est pourtant présente une vilaine
position pour marquer
[Musique]
dès la rentrée et que je t'aime mon
chéri la vessie entreprises un jour j'ai
vraiment envie de te taper la lutte judo
n'est pas assez d'amour
[Musique]
voilà voilà
pour quel same as far marrakech ya du
monde et michael pearson la droite à
gauche mais c'est vrai je me sépare et
coûter cher
[Applaudissements]
konarka cela ne vous ait des cds
structurés castaldi petite up question à
faire sinon tu vas faire tino
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé une parade parade comme ça
oui c'est comme ça c'est qu'on verra
amour haine quand il ya moins de monde
d'amitiés avec la frontière entre
l'amour et la déborde et très très
infime antennes uauy la vie et l'amour
la frontière et comment et alors ça
dépend de calais dunoyer
vous vous situez vous par rapport à qui
par rapport à moi on est ce que
j'appelle à une amitié amoureuse
ah oui on le voulait oui d'autres choses
bouclées
oui une vraie amitié est en train de
naître sous nos yeux et oui kelly après
un début d'histoire compliquée avec
votre voisin
et bien vous n'avez pas à lâcher la
sphère kelly vous avez enfin réussi à
apprivoiser notre petit fabien kelly la
guerrière
c'est parti
[Musique]
enfin je vous fais savoir
[Applaudissements]
des fois par des mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les frimas
m
la part de fiat
j'en ai
consommer
la teom son père de quoi
parce que je savais
c'est jeudi
allez
[Applaudissements]
à
il est clean ouais
désolé les mecs h menthe et clean fabien
brava quoi maintenant il a pas le choix
jusqu'à maintenant il a dit jusqu'à
maintenant non je suis comme son père
depuis on s'entend bien
non je dois beaucoup oui alors un
nouveau couple est en train de se créer
dans la bande à cyril gautier et oui ils
se sont regardés puis re regarder puis
re re re re re regarder cela il doit
passer pâte à papier c'est son nom lui
peut pas et bien sûr le couple le plus
improbable du pal ceux qui ont regarde
souffre
au rayon pour avoir le génie d'un homme
intéressant
[Applaudissements]
et comptez sur les 106
[Musique]
regardez mais je n'ai jamais compris
toutes les messieurs comme il est gros
et yasini bouge pas une fois qu'ils
l'ont empaillés mais ils ont mis comme
mais médoc il est il et il échoue
derrière une connerie non il y là il ya
un mois d'avril amoureux de l'amour dont
il est il est aussi ouvert les idées il
est ouvert d'esprit à la haye alors déjà
invité chez toi enfin non mais il échoue
il est très technique très cher la gare
sont unis à machin je dis pas du tout
qu'il ne sait que je connais pas cette
solide mais il aime les gens
voilà enfin si vous avez encore en
bouteille c'est plus facile alors
d'autres choses des pmp c'est une grande
et belle famille ou ses seins
vous aimez tellement vrai c'est vrai
mais vous le dit souvent mais à votre
manière quoi et franchement je trouve ça
tellement beau elle adore la tp family
c'est pas folichon
[Musique]
benjamin button et la peine
j'avais là les mots ça valait bien les
petites ma passion savoir ça à votre
vocabulaire
regardez je suis tombé je suis n'a pas
souhaité mais je ne savais pas céder
[Musique]
l'anniversaire
montagné patricia canada
et son camion ces bons qui est en train
de se doucher avant d'apprécier à la
galerie là après plein la gueule avec le
soumettant rigoler c'est devenu à neuf
essais à san roque de pâques c'est un
keeper surprise voilà oui d'autres choix
pour puyol c'est eric naulleau est
toujours prêt de faire des petits
plaisirs
ouais et cette semaine eric nous offre
une petite sucrerie mhz alors je sais
qu'il faut pas abuser des bonnes choses
mais là c'était juste un tennis ou et je
connais un qui va prendre cher c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
j'y pensais
c'est très possible que je frappe et
rythme non marine abandon alors oui mais
tu as une exception à chaque règle tu
étais dans la rubrique ma came second
c'est un escroc ouais douleur muette en
escroquant non merci rikimaru l
extraordinaire parce que c'est une sorte
de colombiens chaque cas ce qui est très
très fort c'est qu'elle est 3 et l c'est
autre chose que de l'emmo 82 but de
neymar
bonjour au tournoi capitaine marc loos
mais je suis sûr que vous allez faire un
peu con semblables je suis certain que
j'allais faire après quand on cherche à
te fait quoi décision est prise il
m'avait invité pour être l'invité
vedette de sa prochaine émission de quoi
j'me mêle
ouais je refuse l'invitation à écouter
on vient de me dire quelle belle
nouvelle pour cette dernière chose oui
on va rester sur la sensualité
pendant l'émission je me surprends à
fermer les yeux parfois je suis
transporté très loin vraiment très
l'autre trop loin peut-être je ne sais
pas mais je dois avoir certainement
l'esprit mal placé
enfin comme le tour cette table est bien
quand on n'a pas les imageurs ça donne
ça regarde et on vous le fait ou serrés
et puis il va avoir mal fait chauffer
série la mort chauffer mais on durand
qui met bien en forme c'est dur un
malheur
c'est bon pour les cheveux cette école
comme à défiler le bras oui exactement
voilà merci pukki pour cette semaine
chéri mais je vous en prie